we all know the news media in this
country is abusively biased I have a
special challenge for NBC News they lead
the pack now for decades the incredibly
liberal left-wing news network has been
covering for both Bill and Hillary
Clinton this effort has been led by NBC
News chairman Andy lack is his name he
also ran the company in the late 1990s
now the very same time that Juanita
Broderick accused then President Bill
Clinton of rape and as the Washington
Post reported NBC sat on that interview
with product for at least a month saying
all the story wasn't corroborated at the
time well that's not what Lisa Myers
told juanita and they finally aired it
in February 99 are challenged to Andy
lack NBC News simple air the interview
with Juanita Broderick in its entirety
on NBC and primetime let the people in
this country see and hear and decide for
themselves what former President Bill
Clinton is accused of doing certainly
going to be better than those Dateline
reruns at nauseam that you play NBC News
Andy lack you're gonna give Juanita
Broderick
the proper platform that you sat on or
is Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton's
reputation still that important to you
they don't have power anymore
all right that's all the time